- [Announcer:] Brogon inside...
Oh!
[Crowd roaring]
- I wanna win a championship here.
I feel as though I fit in to the identity of this team very well as an underdog,
and this team always exceeds the expectations.
It takes after the Midwest city that really fights for everything they have.
I've been asked to be the leader of this team,
affect the game on both ends of the floor,
flip criticism on its head
and be elite.
A lot of the time I try to block it out,
but for the criticism that I do hear,
it's fuel to my fire.
Technology is allowing the game to be viewed more widely.
It's made it more interesting for fans, being able to see the different views,
being able to see the game sort of through a different lens and a different angle.
For me personally, I feel as though I fit in to the identity of this team
as an underdog that overperforms,
that proves people wrong.
- [Announcer:] Great move.
- I think we have the building blocks to be really, really good, to be elite.
That will allow us to win a championship ultimately.
I'mma lead with my voice.
I'mma make sure people organize so they know what they're doing.
Then I'mma lead by example.
I'm a guy that's gonna be fearless on the court so that my teammates can follow.